the final episode of American Horror
Story 1984 is just one week away and we
have an absolutely awesome preview to go
along with it as always if you haven't
seen it yet I've left a link in the
description so check it out then come on
back we are in the future or at least it
seems to be with the introduction of
Aegeus alum Finn whit rock he was last
seen four traying jeffer Polk in season
six is Roanoke just look how cute he is
we're in the future judging by the
absolute state of disrepair this places
in there are leaves on the bed the
bathrobes are dusty as all hell and we
can still see the VIP experience banner
in the corner here this all points to
Margaret's plan not working in episode 8
she wanted the massacre to take place so
that she could convert the camp into a
tourist attraction but it seems several
years have passed and the ghosts are
still here and no such attraction has
been made my best guess is that Finn
here is grown up Bobby Richter mr.
jingles his son who he left to be taken
care of by his sister-in-law in Alaska
meaning this would take place somewhere
closer to present-day Montana and Trevor
want to show him how they can kill
themselves which means that Trevor does
end up killed next episode I also think
that Finn's character brought this gun
himself considering the history redwood
has with murder he's here searching for
answers about what happened with his
father we get this shot of Richard
Ramirez which kind of looks like he's
awakening or resurrecting and it could
mean two things one he was previously
incapacitated and he's waking up or two
he's been killed and this is him
resurrecting by Satan or the curse that
covers redwood we just don't know the
final shot of the preview is him at
night swinging a knife in what appears
to be the same location now I've gone
back and looked at and my best guess is
that this is Lavinia Shack they both
have these lanterns and basically look
like [ __ ] now the ending that makes
sense for Ricky is if he were somehow
trapped at redwood for eternity with no
way of getting out which is what this
preview seems to suggest especially when
you pair it with Margaret's voiceover
where she says if you
dead is all you'll ever be so she's
likely seeing this line to someone who
is still alive Lavinia Schack also seems
to play a role with Xavier wielding a
chainsaw over here I wouldn't be
surprised if some big event happens at
this Shack that somehow revolves around
Lavinia Bobby and the curse we get a
brief shot of red Meadows asylum
accompanied by Brooks voiceover telling
her story it seems like she may be the
final girl after all we see she's in
plain clothes here and looking a bit
older my guess is that if she is telling
her story to someone it would be
absolutely awesome if it was Lana
winters who was portrayed by Sarah
paulsen in September according to
Entertainment Tonight Paulson said she
quote may pop up on this season so
here's crossing our fingers we'll see
her we have these shots of Brooks
meshing Margaret into some glass and
this has to be back in 1989 as we'll see
her in the same jacket and later Donna
in the same outfit from episode 8 this
shot here is very interesting we have
Donna looking like she's in distress
with what appears to be Chet and Trevor
coming to her rescue this matches up
with this shot later in the preview with
Donna emerging from a door holding a
knife my best guess to take on Margaret
we get a quick glance of Margaret
loading her gun at night and Finn being
restrained by some orderlies this shot
raises many questions first this seems
to take place at red Meadows Asylum
where his father was also a patient the
fact that he's in street clothes
suggests he's not a patient here my best
guess is that he is searching for
answers about his father and when he
doesn't get what he needs has to be
restrained this could also possibly take
place after he goes to Redwood and needs
to be taken as a patient after he tells
everyone of the ghosts and no one
believes his crazy story my predictions
for this episode Margaret and Ricky will
die Brooke will be the final girl and
jingles son may hold the key to saving
the ghost set redwood there's also no
indication that the massacre Margaret
was planning actually happens but the
vibe I'm getting is that it is somehow
foiled now this is all just for fun and
I hope you've had a blast watching my
AHS videos I'll be here next week with
the final episode breakdown and
all this year doing different shows and
movies so I hope you'll like and
subscribe to my channel and until next
eight just preview a year from now
remember daddy loves you very much